Je suis stressée de ce qu’on va voir...
et je suis stressée aussi de ce qu’on va faire parce que ce n’est pas anodin quand même
de faire ce qu’on va faire ce soir.
Salut à tous, c’est Morgane Little Gypsy et je suis avec Charlie Danger.
Ouais et aujourd’hui on va s’infiltrer dans un élevage de porcs intensif en Bretagne.
On va essayer d’observer un peu les conditions de vie de ces animaux
et comment est-ce qu’ils sont traités. Voilà, c’est la mission du jour.
Étonnamment je ne suis pas stressée, je suis plus anxieuse.
Et William, il n’est pas stressé.
C’est juste qu’il faut tout regarder. Où sont les cochons morts
Faut chercher, ça prend du temps.
Je préférerais être dans ma chambre, être dans mon lit.
Alors pourquoi tu n’es pas dans ta chambre ou dans ton lit ?
Parce qu’il faut le faire quand même, il faut que les gens voient les vidéos
parce que franchement, les gens, ils ne sont pas au courant. Ils pensent que
les cochons, ils sont élevés en plein air.
Ils ne se posent même pas de question en fait, ils n’imaginent même pas je pense.
C’est là-bas. On va descendre un peu plus bas. Après, on remonte un petit peu et c’est là-bas à droite.
S’il y a une voiture qui passe, on se planque dans le champ et on se couche par terre.”
Là, il est minuit et William, il nous emmène dans le premier local,
celui qui est juste derrière toi, là où c’est normalement une salle d’engraissage.”
Les premières salles, c’est des cochons. De tous les côtés, il va y avoir des cochons.
Il fait chaud.
Il ne faudra pas vous inquiéter quand on rentre. Ils sont tellement surpris que des fois, ils se mettent à bouger et à gueuler un peu.
Déjà là, je me sens un peu...
étouffée quoi... Tu sens que t’es…
Ils n’ont même pas l’espace de parcourir 10 mètres.
Ils ne sont que face au mur. Il y a une petite fenêtre qui met un petit peu de lumière à l’intérieur.
Là, les petites traces de griffures, c’est parce qu’ils se battent, ils s’agressent entre eux.
À la naissance, ils ont les dents coupés pour éviter justement de se mordre et de se blesser en se mordant.
Et on voit qu’ils ont tous des petites queues parce qu’ils l’ont tous eu coupées, en fait.
C’est parce qu’ils se la mangent entre eux ?
Eh ouais, ils n’ont rien à faire. Eux, ils ont envie de mordiller des trucs, ils ont envie de mâcher des trucs.
Ils se bousculent sans arrêt, en permanence. Ils sont stressés, ils n’ont aucun espace donc ils se blessent comme ça.
C’est vraiment horrible et ceux qui verront la vidéo,
ls ne se rendront pas compte, mais ça sent vraiment mauvais.
Il fait super chaud et je n’imagine même pas l’été comment ça doit être. C’est horrible quoi.
Toute la terre qu’ils ont sur eux, ce n’est pas de la terre
Ce sont des excréments et ce n’est pas seulement sur les fesses, c’est sur le museau, c’est partout.
Là, c’est tous les excréments et l’urine qui tombent.
Ils ont mis ce système de sols ajourés comme ça ils n’ont pas besoin de sortir les cochons des box.
Les cochons peuvent rester ici plusieurs semaines mais il y a quand même plein d’excréments qui restent.
Donc, à chaque fois qu’ils se couchent, ils se couchent dans leurs excréments.
C’est légal, genre ça c’est autorisé, c’est normal.
Le but, c’est de faire le plus de profit possible
d’avoir des cochons qui vont grossir le plus vite possible, à moindre coût,
en dépensant le moins d’énergie, le moins de travail, le moins de main-d'œuvre, le moins de nourriture.
Donc le but, c’est la rentabilité, ce n’est pas du tout le bien-être animal, ça c’est sûr.
Il y a de la nourriture qui est distribuée automatiquement dans leur gamelle
une espèce de bouillie, c’est de l’eau mélangée avec des céréales.
Là, c’est vide encore. Et voilà, tout ce qu’ils font, c’est manger, dormir et chier et c’est tout, ils tournent en rond.”
Tu vois, ça vient tout juste de tomber la nourriture.
Là, ils sont tous en train de bouffer.
Donc en fait, ils les réveillent la nuit pour les nourrir ?
À mon avis ouais, c’est ce qu’il se passe parce que là s’ils dormaient, la nourriture, elle serait tombée.
En plus, ils attendaient la nourriture donc ils se réveillent tous.
Voir de visu comme ça ce qui, finalement, va se retrouver dans nos assiettes,
là je prends vraiment conscience des conditions de vie.
ls se marchent les uns sur les autres.
Je n’arrive pas à croire que ce soit l’Homme qui fasse ça
Je me sens très coupable.
J’ai consommé de la viande pendant une grosse partie de ma vie, et ma prise de conscience végétarienne,
elle s’est faite relativement tardivement.
Et quand je vois ça, je me dis juste que j’ai honte
En tant que consommateur, quand on achète une barquette de jambon,
on n’a pas en tête ce qui est en train de se passer actuellement, on se dit juste :
“Oh, c’est du jambon, ce sont des jolies tranches toutes roses."
"Ça me fait du bien, ça va être très bien dans mon croque-monsieur.”
On n’a pas forcément en tête l’impact que ça peut avoir sur les animaux.
Il est en train de crever celui-là.
Là, ça fait peut-être deux, trois heures qu’il se fait piétiner
J’entends beaucoup de personnes dans mon entourage dire :
“Oh, moi, toutes ces images-là, je ne veux surtout pas les voir sinon ça va me dégoûter.”
Mais justement, si vous savez que ça va vous dégoûter, c’est qu’il y a une raison.
Donc, à partir de là, il faut se demander pourquoi ?
Est-ce qu’on a vraiment envie de cautionner ça ?
Est-ce qu’on a envie d’être une civilisation qui cautionne ce genre de choses, qui le fait ?
Moi, en tout cas, ça me fait réfléchir et je me pose sincèrement la question.
Ici, on vient d’arriver dans le bâtiment des maternités.
Donc c’est là où les petits porcelets naissent et qu’ils gardent les truies dans des cages fermées
et vous allez voir, c’est juste ici.
Il y a un bébé mort les gars. Juste là dans le couloir.
Et après, ils les ramassent et les mettent à la poubelle.
Là, tu as un bébé qui est en train de mourir.
Juste là, il y a une mère qui est entre…
attends, excuse-moi, je suis en train de buguer…
Leur regard, même leur regard,
tu vois qu’il y a de la détresse, il y a tellement de détresse
C’est horrible, là je pense que c’est le pire qu’on ait vu.”
Les femelles, elles n’ont aucun espace pour vivre.
Là, on a l’exemple type de l’espace qu’elles peuvent avoir.
Elles n’ont aucun espace à part si elles se mettent debout et puis voilà
elles sont contraintes à être allongées pour pouvoir allaiter et c’est tout ce qu’elles peuvent faire.
Je ne peux pas comprendre qu’on puisse manger cette viande derrière, ce n’est pas possible.
Tout le monde devrait être confronté à cette réalité-là.
Et se rendre compte de nos actes et de la manière dont on consomme tous les jours
Parce que ça, ce qu’on est en train de voir, c’est de notre faute en fait.
Ils vont rester 20 jours ici.
Ils sont sevrés au bout de 20 jours, alors que normalement les animaux
ils sont sevrés au bout de 2 mois mais dans l’élevage industriel,
ils vont les séparer au bout de 20 jours et dans les 5 premiers jours
ils doivent les castrer donc ils vont arracher à vif les testicules avec des pinces coupantes.
- Et les petits, ils vont dans les salles qu’on a vues au début ?
- Exactement, ils sont déplacés dans d’autres salles et puis après quand ils grossissent un peu trop,
dans d’autres salles encore et au fur et à mesure…
Là, ce sont tous les petits qui n’ont pas survécu,
les fœtus et tous ceux qui sont morts-nés.
- Ah, c’est dégueu.
- Elles sont sélectionnées génétiquement,
pour faire des portées plus nombreuses et elles peuvent faire des portées de 12, 13, 14 petits porcelets.
Tous ne survivent pas et certains vont mourir dans les premières heures
ou les premiers jours de leur naissance.
- Ce n’est pas un élevage, c’est un film d’horreur.
Ce qui choque le plus, c’est quand on rentre dans ces lieux-là,
c’est l’ambiance olfactive, parce que c’est une odeur qui est vraiment très, très dure…
Je pense que là nos vêtements vont être imprégnés…
- Là, c’est le lendemain, on a tous les vêtements, c’est l’horreur.
Quand tu es sur place, tu te rends vraiment compte à quel point on s’en fout de ces animaux.
Il y en avait qui étaient éparpillés un peu partout, qui étaient morts.
- On a vraiment entendu, à certains moments, des cris de souffrances,
des cris d’alertes. On dirait une salle de torture en fait.
- C’est vraiment ça.
- C’est une salle de torture.
- Clairement, si on ne change pas notre façon de consommer la viande, ça changera jamais ce qu’on a vu hier soir.
- Il faudrait une prise de conscience collective, ou alors,
ouvrir ces lieux au public pour que tout le monde puisse s’y rendre et constater par soi-même et après,
prendre la décision de consommer de la viande mais que ce soit un choix “sensé”
que ce soit un choix en ayant toutes les cartes en main pour comprendre ce que ça implique.
Après la soirée d’hier dans un élevage intensif de plus de 2000 cochons,
on a décidé de partir dans les Landes chez un éleveur qui en élève juste 4,
et qui va nous expliquer comment il fait,
et les solutions pour pouvoir en arriver là et pouvoir élever des cochons de manière éthique.
Ici, on est à Camdelan, la ferme fantastique.
C’est une petite ferme qu’on a créée avec ma compagne, il y a 3 ans.
On est à la fois éleveurs de porcs gascons, de brebis landaises, de chèvres des Pyrénées, de poules gasconnes
On a des canards. Les porcs gascons, ils vont avoir finalement une vie qui va…
On va tenter en tout cas de la rapprocher le plus possible de ce qu’ils auraient connu dans un milieu naturel.
Ils vont trouver en permanence sur le sol tout un tas d’aliments.
Ça va être de l’herbe bien sûr, qui représente une grande partie de leur alimentation.
Ça va être des vers parce qu’il y a beaucoup de vers dans le sol, c’est un sol vivant.
Ça va être des larves, ça va être des racines, voilà tout un tas de choses.
On va quand même les nourrir un petit peu, il y aura un complément,
ce n’est pas grand chose.
C’est des restes de végétaux, des restes de légumes de la ferme,
c’est les patates qui ont germées de l’année dernière qu’on va cuire.
C’est de l’ortie aussi. Des anciens qui m’ont dit ça :
"Une poignée d’orties par jour et les cochons ne verront jamais le vétérinaire”
et je ne sais pas si c’est vrai mais ils n’ont jamais vu le vétérinaire.
En tout cas, on a jamais eu de pépin sur la ferme.
- Ils ont besoin de faire quoi ces animaux pour leur bien-être ?
- C’est courir, manger équilibré.
C’est une bonne sociabilisation, c’est ne pas être stressés dans son environnement.
C’est tout un tas de choses finalement,
dont nous-mêmes avons besoin pour notre développement personnel.
Tous les jours, on travaille énormément, je ne le cache pas.
C’est beaucoup de boulot mais on y prend beaucoup de plaisir.
C’est gratifiant, les gens reviennent vers nous, les gens nous reparlent,
nous disent qu’ils ont retrouvé un goût dans nos rillettes,
dans notre jambon qu’ils n’avaient pas trouvé depuis un moment parce que notre cochon, il a du goût,
parce que ce cochon, il n’a pas été élevé à l’eau et aux antibiotiques donc,
forcément, ça développe des arômes différents.
Alors là, on va aller préparer le seau de nourriture pour le soir.
On fait ça matin et soir.
C’est une petite mixture de tout un tas d’aliments qu’on récupère soit sur la ferme,
des restes de cultures, ça change tous les jours en fonction de ce qu’on a.
Alors vous allez voir, ça c’est le meilleur moment de la journée.
Ils le savent, ils le savent que c’est l’heure.
Hein, vous le savez ?
Et voilà. Les animaux nous le rendent bien.
Les animaux sont en pleine forme, les animaux sont moins stressés,
moins malades, voire pas du tout malades.
J’ai choisi d’être un éleveur respectueux et de faire les choses le mieux possible.
On a fait beaucoup par nous-mêmes, c’est de la débrouille, c’est des réseaux locaux.
- T’arrives à t’en sortir maintenant ?
- Ça fait trois ans, là on vient de faire notre bilan,
c’est plutôt positif, on est dans le vert, ça fait vraiment plaisir.
Mais dans l’élevage industriel, je pense que les investissements sont gigantesques.
Les machines sont énormes, ça coûte des centaines de milliers d’euros.
Alors, même si certaines sont subventionnées, ça leur prend parfois quinze ans, vingt ans,
et ils finissent par vivre endettés.
Ce qui les amène à travailler comme ça finalement,
c’est cet espace d’emballement depuis les années 30 pour une production très intensive, très spécialisée.
Nous, les règles du jeu, on a décidé de les écrire nous-mêmes.
Il y a encore des paysans, debout, qui ont connu les techniques paysannes anciennes
et qui les pratiquent encore aujourd’hui.
Le lien, il n’est pas complètement brisé,
je pense qu’on peut encore rétablir les choses.
- Est-ce que tu penses aussi qu’il faudrait que le Français,
il réduise sa consommation de viande ?
Je connais tout un tas de gens qui mangent de la viande tous les jours,
voire tous les repas. Nous, notre intérêt,
ce n’est pas que les gens mangent plus de viande, c’est que les gens mangent mieux de la viande.
Nous, on n’est pas prêt à fournir des grandes quantités
mais on est prêt à fournir de la qualité donc on arrivera à se retrouver sur ce terrain là.
Si tous les consommateurs se décidaient, demain,
à aller voir les petits producteurs pour essayer de fournir localement de bons produits,
il se passera quelque chose de très simple,
c’est que tous les autres producteurs, ils vont s’adapter.
Ils vont s’adapter parce qu’aujourd’hui, quoiqu’on veuille
on est pris par les lois du marché, de l’offre et la demande.
On peut difficilement s’en extraire.
Et si les gens consomment mieux,
alors les producteurs produiront mieux.